être voilà bonjour merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur arte france alors
selon vous cette proposition de loi
fait-elle l'objet d'un passage en force
par le gouvernement au vu des divisions
qu'elle continue de susciter
il est il est en tout cas très étonnant
que cette loi interviennent en cette
période particulièrement délicate au
niveau parlementaire qui est celle de
l'état d'urgence et qu'on ait trouvé
qu'il y avait encore plus urgent que la
crise sanitaire du covin pour faire
passer cette loi qui est débattu depuis
déjà de nombreux mois devant le
parlement donc oui c'est très étonnant
que au niveau calendrier en tout cas que
cette loi intervient cet après midi
alors que rien ne justifiait une telle
urgence pour la faire passer en raison
en plus de son caractère très très
controversé et justement beaucoup de
dans l'opposition mais aussi au sein de
certaines ong et associations dénoncent
une menace pour la liberté d'expression
ils ont raison ils ont raison en fait
cette loi alors tout le monde bien
évidemment est d'accord pour contenir la
haine sur internet est là et la
combattre bien sûr c'est une excellente
initiative
au départ mais c'est comme dans le conte
du petit chaperon rouge on a on a un
loup déguisé en grand mère est en fait
sous des atours qui sont qui peuvent
paraître superficiellement extrêmement
intéressant au niveau de la la
suppression des contenus haineux on se
retrouve avec un une
un monstre avec avec de grandes orgues
qui veut croquer dans la liberté
d'expression et je partage complètement
l'avis de du député rufin que vous avez
passé tout à l'heure on a aujourd'hui
une loi qui est potentiellement
liberticide et avec un risque de sur 100
sur des par la part de la part de
facebook de twitter et des réseaux
sociaux
bien sûr les contenus on va avoir en
livre les clés du camion delà de la
censure sur internet aux gaffes assez
c'est assez
c'est assez troublant et c'est pas faute
de l'avoir de l'avoir remarqué le sénat
avait délivré de nombreux amendements
ils n'ont pas été suivis et j'ai très
très peur que cet après midi à
l'assemblée nationale les députés ne
votent en l'état le projet de loi avec
ses articles et notamment l'article 1
qui est extrêmement inquiétant alors là
on parle même plus de 2 200 / par par
les réseaux sociaux mais donne à peu
sibilité pour les contenus terroristes
d'être enlevée en moins d'une heure il
faudra lorsqu un signalement de police
interviendra sur un contenu
potentiellement terroriste que facebook
ou twitter enlève ses contenus en moins
en moins d'une heure mais qui définira
la la nature supposés terroristes de ces
contenus c'est la police ce n'est même
pas un juge
donc on a de multiples multiples
faisceaux d'indicés qui démontre
qu'aujourd'hui cette loi via ne doit pas
être votée en l'état elle est
complètement complètement insensé au
niveau de la de la liberté d'expression
et j'ai bien peur que aujourd'hui on
ouvre la boîte de pandore et que dès
demain on ne puisse vraiment plus avoir
une une parole libre et une parole
véritablement sereine par rapport à par
rapport à cette réglementation qui ne
s'imposait pas et qui donne en plus des
pouvoirs extraordinairement important au
csa qui n'a absolument rien à faire sur
le la régulation sur internet mais à qui
le gouvernement semble décidément
véritablement désireux de délivrer des
des pouvoirs exorbitants
on verra ce que le conseil
constitutionnel on dira parce que
j'imagine qu'il sera saisie une fois la
loi votée cet après-midi alors dernière
question selon le texte un parc est une
juridiction seront spécialisés dans la
lutte contre la haine en ligne on a
l'impression que le gouvernement veut
remettre au centre la justice est-ce
suffisant selon vous alors c'est très
bien alors là pour le coup la création
de ce parc est alors c'est pas le
premier des parcs est spécialisé on en a
déjà beaucoup
le parquet financier notamment si le
parquet a des moyens bien sûr ça sera
parfait mais il faut encore que ces
magistrats puissent avoir des moyens
aujourd'hui on en manque cruellement
je les gens les débattu avec est ici à
abyei encore quelques semaines donner
des moyens à la justice
alors on en parle beaucoup en ce moment
la grève des avocats avant le locaux
vides étaient aussi sur 7 sur cette voie
là il faut aujourd'hui c'est pas tout de
créer des institutions de créer des
parcs et spécialisés faut-il encore
qu'ils aient des moyens des moiteurs des
moyens matériels des moyens humains et
c'est comme ça peut-être on arrivera à
réguler mais bon cette création en tout
cas c'est peut-être une des seules
bonnes choses de cette loi
m e thierry val avocat au barreau de
paris merci d'avoir répondu à nos
questions
merci